hi there steve again continuing my
korean challenge uh
cleaned up after dinner i'm gonna go off
and do some korean reading on link but i
just uh had a thought that i wanted to
share with you
uh somebody came on my channel here and
said and i get this from time to time
uh you know what's the point of uh
being uh intermediate at best in so many
languages you're better off to be really
good at a few uh
you know why do you pretend you're
fluent when you're not and and words of
that effect
and i've had people come on before you
know your chinese is really quite
mediocre and stuff so
in praise of mediocrity
i think it's great to be intermediate in
a language i think it's great to be
mediocre in a language because we learn
languages for ourselves so if i can
communicate if i can read and listen to
things that interest me
and i can communicate with people
i'm happy
uh i think it was catholic the famous
hungarian
uh polyglot of the 20th century who said
language is the only thing
worth knowing poorly
or something to that effect
so i think people should just accept
whatever they achieve be happy for it be
happy for what they're able to do enjoy
every moment they spend with the
language which i do i
you know and sometimes i have to remind
myself
you know i'm working through my career
and i don't think i'm making progress
but i'm enjoying it i'm learning about
stuff so mediocrity is good
it's good
because you have to enjoy every moment
that you're spending with the language
not to mention the fact that to be
intermediate in a language is pretty
good and particularly if it's based on
good comprehension which i consider to
be the most important thing
if you get more opportunity to speak
you'll end up speaking better so
there you have it now i was asked by
someone i can't remember
who
who said that their girlfriend uh is
chinese and is struggling to learn
english and
could i say a few words of encouragement
to her in chinese so i'll follow this up
with a another video where i'll say more
or less the same thing in chinese to
encourage this learner in china and i
might you know add a few more things to
it but i'm not going to provide a
translation or a transcript story and
there you have it in praise of
mediocrity you know celebrate what
you're able to do enjoy it and don't
worry if you put in enough time you will
improve guaranteed especially if you
enjoy it and in order to enjoy it pat
yourself on the back every now and again
okay bye for now
steve kaufman
youtube channel
um
um
uh